This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's safe to say that Woods Hole is exactly what you picture when you think of a town on Cape God. Old houses covered in wood shingles. There are sailboats, ocean side restaurants. Wealthy vacationers in the summertime. Super traditional, super east coast. But just up the hill from the tiny downtown, there's this huge dome. It looks like a three-story tall golf ball.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。可以肯定地说，伍兹霍尔正是你心目中科德角小镇的样子。古老的房子覆盖着木瓦，有帆船，有海边餐厅，夏天还有富有的度假者。非常传统，非常有东海岸风情。但在离市中心不远的山坡上，有一个巨大的圆顶建筑。它看起来像一个三层楼高的巨大高尔夫球。
It's this crazy looking white building totally out of place next to the old colonial houses. So reporter Katie Cloxon went to check it out. Hello! Katie brought some friends too. The back door was unlocked. It's not like anything you've ever seen before. Inside, it smells musty. It's creepy.
这座看起来很疯狂的白色建筑，在古老的殖民风格房屋旁显得格格不入。于是记者凯蒂·克洛克森去一探究竟。你好！凯蒂还带了一些朋友。后门没锁。这和你以前见过的任何东西都不一样。里面闻起来有一股霉味。令人毛骨悚然。
Look at this old wall paper. There's a wall made entirely out of these interlocking, triangle-shaped windows. They cast a web of shadows on the floor. There's an old kitchen. It looks like it might have been part of a restaurant. You found some? Yeah, there's a whole pile of old salt and pepper.
看看这些旧壁纸。有一面墙完全由这些相互交错的三角形窗户组成。它们在地板上投射出一张阴影网。有一个旧厨房。看起来它可能曾经是一家餐厅的一部分。你找到了吗？是的，有一大堆旧的盐和胡椒瓶。
I don't agree with that. Okay, let's go look. It's kind of spooky. When we left, I needed to know more. What Katie found was a geodesic dome designed and built by the late Buckminster Fuller. Don't feel bad if you've never heard of Bucky. He did go by Bucky by the way. He was a big deal back in the 60s. A drawing of Bucky's head made to look like one of his domes was
我不同意这一点。好吧，我们去看看。这有点阴森。当我们离开时，我需要了解更多。凯蒂发现的是已故的巴克敏斯特·富勒设计并建造的测地线圆顶。如果你没听说过巴基，别觉得不好意思。顺便说一句，他确实叫巴基。他在60年代可是个大人物。一张巴基头像的画被做成了他圆顶的样子，并
on the cover of Time Magazine in 1964. There's a Bucky Fuller postage stamp. He was even given the country's highest civilian honor, a presidential medal of freedom. Bucky Fuller is also responsible for the title of this radio show. He said 99% of who you are is invisible and untouchable, and he discussed the 99% invisible activity that is coalescing to her shape our future.
登上了1964年《时代》杂志的封面。还有一张巴基·富勒的邮票。他甚至被授予了国家最高平民荣誉——总统自由勋章。巴基·富勒也是这个广播节目名称的由来。他说，你99%的本质是隐形且不可触碰的，他讨论了那些正在汇聚并塑造我们未来的99%隐形活动。
He's a very quotable man. Here he is from the film Buckminster Fuller, the lost interviews. I think we ought to be looking into what needs to be done to do more with less so that you might sometimes do so much with so little you might be able to take care of everybody and make all the politics invalid. Jay Baldwin was one of Bucky's students. He just wanted people to use less stuff.
他是一个非常善于引用的人。这是他在电影《巴克敏斯特·富勒：遗失的访谈》中的片段。我认为我们应该研究如何用更少的资源做更多的事，这样你有时可以用极少的资源做如此多的事，你或许能够照顾到每一个人，并使所有的政治变得无效。杰伊·鲍德温是巴基的学生之一。他只是想让人们少用东西。
He said it was all going to run out. We've got to think big and take care of everybody. He said as long as it's one person starving, you're going to have wars. Fuller called himself a comprehensive, anticipatory, design scientist. He wanted to invent things that would make human life sustainable on this planet.
他说资源终将耗尽。我们必须有大局观，照顾到每一个人。他说只要还有一个人在挨饿，就会有战争。富勒称自己为综合性、前瞻性的设计科学家。他想发明能让地球上人类生活可持续的东西。
Decades before anyone else was even thinking about green buildings. And for that, people have called Bucky the Leonardo da Vinci of the 20th century. Oh yes, they do that, but the Vor Institute crew counters that Leonardo was the Bucky for medieval times. So here's the deal with the Woods Hole Dome. Bucky wanted to change the world, starting with buildings. So he started making these weird structures,
早在几十年前，还没人考虑绿色建筑时，他就已经这样做了。因此，人们称巴基为20世纪的列昂纳多·达·芬奇。哦，是的，他们确实这么说，但Vor研究所的团队反驳说，列昂纳多才是中世纪的巴基。所以，关于伍兹霍尔圆顶的事情是这样的。巴基想改变世界，从建筑开始。于是他开始制造这些奇怪的结构，
what she called geodesic domes. Geodesic refers to the geometry of curved surfaces. The golf ball building in Woods Hole is actually the oldest of Bucky's domes that are still standing. The structure of the geodesic dome is based on a lot of complicated math. But in short, it's built with a lot
他称之为测地线圆顶。“测地线”指的是曲面的几何形状。伍兹霍尔的高尔夫球建筑实际上是巴基现存最古老的圆顶建筑。测地线圆顶的结构基于许多复杂的数学原理。但简而言之，它是用许多
of triangles. A triangle is a very strong shape, and a dome made out of triangles is extra strong. That meant that domes could be made of lighter and cheaper materials than normal buildings, like plastic and aluminum instead of steel and concrete. Back in 1952, Bucky was just starting to build domes. They caught the attention of an architect and aspiring restaurant tour, a man named Gunner Peterson. And in the early 50s, 1953, he bought some property in Wittshol and decided to build a hotel in a restaurant.
三角形建造的。三角形是一种非常坚固的形状，由三角形组成的圆顶格外坚固。这意味着圆顶可以用比普通建筑更轻、更便宜的材料制成，比如塑料和铝，而不是钢和混凝土。早在1952年，巴基刚开始建造圆顶。它们引起了一位建筑师兼有抱负的餐馆老板——一个叫冈纳·彼得森的人的注意。在50年代初，即1953年，他在伍兹霍尔买了一些地，决定建一家酒店和餐厅。
Joel Peterson is Gunner's son. He did make a deal with Bucky Fuller. I don't remember how dad met him. He called him up. I don't, you know, I mean, he tracked him down anyway. And Bucky and his wife came and lived at our house. They decided they'd build the dome restaurant. A geodesic dome has a way of standing out, but in Cape Cod it really stands out. And that upset some people. Wow, it isn't their shingled Cape Cod cottage really stands out. And that upsets some people. Wow, it isn't a shingled Cape Cod cottage. That's for darn sure.
乔尔·彼得森是冈纳的儿子。他确实和巴基·富勒达成了协议。我不记得爸爸是怎么认识他的。他给他打了电话。我不知道，我的意思是，他反正找到了他。巴基和他的妻子来到我们家住。他们决定建造圆顶餐厅。测地线圆顶很显眼，但在科德角，它确实非常显眼。这让一些人感到不安。哇，它不是那种铺着木瓦的科德角小屋，确实很显眼。那是肯定的。
And the feeling is this is going to change life as we know it. We'll never be the same again. This is just horrible. One building. There was stuff that happened. There was things stolen. I mean, there was paint poured on you know, I mean there was paint poured on things, there was there was just lots of stuff. Stuff here meaning.
人们的感觉是，这将改变我们所知的生活。我们将永远无法回到过去。这太可怕了。一栋建筑。发生了一些事情。有东西被偷了。我的意思是，有人往东西上泼油漆，我的意思是，有人往东西上泼油漆，有很多事情发生。这里说的“事情”是指。
People didn't want to talk about this on tape, but I just have this mental image of a really ugly mob up in arms about this dome. That's probably an exaggeration, but you get the idea. Despite the unrest, the dome restaurant opened in June of 1954. And according to Joel, it was the place to go. The dome was the most elegant place around, I mean, at that time. And certainly when you went out to eat in the fifties on Cape Cod, in a place like the dome, you wore a tie and the women were all spiffed up.
人们不想在录音中谈论这个，但我脑海中浮现出一群因为这个圆顶而愤怒的丑陋暴民的形象。这可能是一种夸张，但你明白我的意思。尽管有动荡，圆顶餐厅还是在1954年6月开业了。据乔尔说，那是当时最受欢迎的地方。圆顶是周围最优雅的地方，我的意思是，在那个时候。当然，当你在50年代的科德角外出就餐时，在像圆顶这样的地方，你会打领带，女士们也会打扮得漂漂亮亮。
It was a festive occasion. And they had a live musician. She played the Zither. And I don't know if you've ever had dinner with Zither music. It's rather pleasant. The restaurant is right on the ocean. And you're far away from city. so you can just look up at the ceiling and you're looking at the stars. Sally Brady was 14 years old when the dome restaurant opened near her house.
那是一个节日的场合。他们还有现场音乐家。她弹奏齐特琴。我不知道你是否曾经伴着齐特琴音乐吃过晚餐。这相当令人愉快。餐厅就在海边。你远离城市，所以你可以抬头看天花板，看着星星。萨莉·布雷迪在圆顶餐厅在她家附近开业时才14岁。
Those early 50s were really quite an amazing moment because everybody could buy cars. People who survived the war, all those men were home and they were jobs and people were making the American dream come true and I think that the dome was sort of a symbol of the American dream in a way. It felt like a prosperous, optimistic time. It made sense that the dome represented the future for some people. It turned out that there were some real structural problems with the dome. First, the structure acted like an acoustic amplifier.
50年代初确实是一个非常了不起的时刻，因为每个人都能买得起车。那些在战争中幸存下来的人，所有那些男人都回家了，有了工作，人们正在实现美国梦，我认为圆顶在某种程度上是美国梦的象征。那感觉是一个繁荣、乐观的时代。圆顶代表了某些人的未来，这很有道理。事实证明，圆顶存在一些真正的结构性问题。首先，该结构就像一个声学放大器。
So all that zither music got blasted across the neighborhood. And a building with that much glass worked like a greenhouse. So it got hot inside. After the first season, they covered the dome and white fiberglass to block out the sun. That meant diners couldn't see the stars anymore. Geodesic domes don't have any support beams. Those triangular window frames do all the work.
所以所有的齐特琴音乐都在社区里回荡。而且拥有那么多玻璃的建筑就像一个温室。所以里面很热。第一个季节过后，他们用白色玻璃纤维覆盖了圆顶以遮挡阳光。这意味着食客们再也看不到星星了。测地线圆顶没有任何支撑梁。那些三角形的窗框承担了所有的工作。
Each frame rests on the one next to it. Which can be a problem if the building materials are flexible and move in the wind. Here's Arnie Grepstad, he worked at the restaurants. Saturday night, horrible weather outside, and this particular night, there was a party of four, the scallies that were they having dinner, and they were regular customers, local people. Around 730, with a chock full full restaurant all of a sudden it's not dripping at table 113 and I can remember it seeing them sit there and Jane took the rumble out opened it to a huge applause from everyone in the restaurant
每个框架都靠在旁边的框架上。如果建筑材料有弹性并在风中移动，这可能会成为一个问题。这是阿尼·格雷普斯塔德，他在餐厅工作。周六晚上，外面天气很糟糕，那天晚上有四个人，那些常客，当地人，在吃晚餐。大约7点30分，餐厅挤满了人，突然113号桌开始滴水，我记得看到他们坐在那里，简把雨伞撑开，餐厅里响起了巨大的掌声。
it was just funny but the fact is the geodesic domes most of them linked like sivs again Jay Baldwin Bucky's former student. I have a photograph of Bucky inside his dome in Carbondale with an umbrella in one hand, a book in the other, and a flashlight in his mouth reading the book. And the umbrella is needed. I told Bucky I'm going to find out why domes leak and he said domes leak because they made my amateurs and they built it with holes in it. You wouldn't build a boat with holes in it. Would you har har? And I said I don't think they're leaking because
这很有趣，但事实是，大多数测地线圆顶像筛子一样漏水。再次提到杰伊·鲍德温，巴基的前学生。我有一张巴基在他卡本代尔圆顶里的照片，一只手拿着雨伞，另一只手拿着书，嘴里叼着手电筒在看书。雨伞是必需的。我告诉巴基，我要找出圆顶漏水的原因，他说圆顶漏水是因为它们是业余爱好者制造的，而且建造时留下了洞。你不会造一艘有洞的船，对吧？哈哈。我说我不认为它们漏水是因为
they made them with a hole in it. I said I think they're leaking g desiccly. The owner Joel Peterson says he patched a lot of leaks. Eventually, Joel wanted to retire from the restaurant business. He sold the property in 2002. It's been sitting vacant ever since. I asked Joel and Arne to give me a tour. I can't bring myself to tell them I've actually been here before. We have to push aside branches to get to the front door.
它们造的时候留了洞。我说我认为它们是“测地线式”地漏水。业主乔尔·彼得森说他修补了很多漏洞。最终，乔尔想从餐饮业退休。他在2002年卖掉了这处房产。从那以后它一直空置着。我请乔尔和阿尼带我参观。我无法告诉他们我其实以前来过这里。我们必须拨开树枝才能到达前门。
It's been a few years since I've been here. And to tell you the truth, I never really wanted to come because I mean, it is incredibly overgrown. I mean, it's just sad. Oh my gosh, isn't this amazing? It actually, I actually have a key. Yo, it is. I'll tell you what, this is not a pretty sight.
我来这里已经几年了。说实话，我从来没想过要来，因为我的意思是，它长满了杂草。我的意思是，这太令人难过了。天哪，这不令人惊叹吗？它实际上，我确实有一把钥匙。哟，确实是。我告诉你，这可不是什么好看的景象。
I told you about Ruth while coming to the other. This is where she played. Now, you want to take a look at the kitchen? There's a walking cooler there and the prep room in the back. This really has been my work in life. I certainly wouldn't mind seeing it restored. On the other hand, I think it's going to be a tremendous expense to put this back. So it's with two opposite emotions that you'll look at it.
我告诉过你关于露丝来这里的事。这是她演奏的地方。现在，你想看看厨房吗？那里有一个步入式冷藏库，后面是准备室。这确实是我一生的工作。我当然不介意看到它被修复。另一方面，我认为修复它将是一笔巨大的开支。所以，带着两种相反的情绪看着它。
But you have to be realistic and understand that things change here in life. In 2006, a real estate development company planned to build condos on the site. And for a while, it looked like the dome might be torn down. But then a funny thing happened. There was a public outcry to keep the dome. This is the same building that residents fought against tooth and nail back when it was being constructed in the 50s. Now, in order to build on the site, the developer has to restore the dome. And that's going to be expensive.
但你必须现实一点，明白生活中的事情会改变。2006年，一家房地产开发公司计划在该地块建造公寓。有一段时间，圆顶看起来可能会被拆除。但后来发生了一件有趣的事。公众强烈要求保留圆顶。这正是50年代建造时居民们拼命反对的同一栋建筑。现在，为了在该地块上施工，开发商必须修复圆顶。那将是非常昂贵的。
So the whole thing is in limbo until more condos are pre-sold. And real estate transactions are not moving quickly these days. If the developer can't pre-sell enough condos to justify the cost of restoring the dome, then the whole deal could fall apart. If that happened, the dome would stay as it is now, continuing to decay, waiting for the next out of towners to come poking around with a flashlight. The person who seems least sentimental about this is Joel Peterson. If I were doing the project that they talk about doing, I'd tear it down.
所以整件事在更多公寓预售之前都处于悬而未决的状态。而且这些天房地产交易进展缓慢。如果开发商不能预售足够的公寓来证明修复圆顶的成本是合理的，那么整个交易可能会破裂。如果发生这种情况，圆顶将保持现状，继续腐烂，等待下一个带着手电筒四处窥探的外地人。看起来对这件事最不感伤的人是乔尔·彼得森。如果我在做他们谈论的那个项目，我会把它拆了。
Be honest with you. It's a building. It was part of my life, it's a building. Sally Brady, who grew up next to the dome, feels differently. Maybe it will be reborn in a different way that will be better. Why not? Maybe it will be a beautiful transparent place and people will go there and do fantastic energizing work that will help humanity.
老实说。它只是一栋建筑。它是我生活的一部分，但它是一栋建筑。在圆顶旁边长大的萨莉·布雷迪感觉不同。也许它会以一种更好的方式重生。为什么不呢？也许它会成为一个美丽的透明空间，人们会去那里做奇妙的、充满活力的工作，这将有助于人类。
What do you think we would lose if it was torn down? What would we lose? Well, it's a very good example of this repost for 50 boom and anything was possible Yeah, I sort of agree and then and then what does that mean that now? It's just in such disrepair Well, I think it means that we've moved on and that dream went bust, sort of, yeah, I think it's a kind of broken dream right now. I sort of depressing, isn't it? Maybe a finished dream is a little kinder.
你认为如果它被拆除，我们会失去什么？我们会失去什么？嗯，它是50年代繁荣时期的一个很好的例子，当时一切皆有可能。是的，我有点同意，然后呢，那意味着什么？现在它破败不堪。嗯，我认为这意味着我们已经向前看了，那个梦想破灭了，某种程度上，是的，我认为它现在是一种破碎的梦想。有点令人沮丧，不是吗？也许说“完成的梦想”会更委婉一点。
Buckminster Fuller claimed that his ideas were 50 years ahead of his time. And now it's been over 50 years, but domes have not replaced traditional buildings. But you know what? I'm rooting for the dome. I think it represents Bucky's optimism that we could solve the world's problems with good design. And even if you couldn't, you could still stargaze through triangular windows,
巴克敏斯特·富勒声称他的想法领先于时代50年。现在已经过去50多年了，但圆顶并没有取代传统建筑。但你知道吗？我支持圆顶。我认为它代表了巴基的乐观精神，即我们可以通过好的设计解决世界上的问题。即使你做不到，你仍然可以通过三角形的窗户仰望星空，
looking out over the sea. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Cloxon with Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. Katie produced a different version of this story at the Transom Story Workshop, which aired on the PRX How Sound Podcast. Both of those are run by the great super punk rock. Rob Rosenfall. Do they owe us a living? Thanks also to Aaron Chichesky. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible.
眺望大海。《99%隐形》本周由凯蒂·克洛克森制作，萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯参与。凯蒂在Transom故事工作坊制作了这个故事的另一个版本，并在PRX的《How Sound》播客上播出。这两个节目都由伟大的超级朋克罗伯·罗森塔尔运营。他们欠我们生活吗？也感谢亚伦·奇切斯基。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，
You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。